thank you
thank you 45 years ago I was offered a
movie entitled sounder it was the first
major movie that I would have done in my
career on the way to the airport to fly
out here I stopped by a very close and
long time dear friend's home to share
the news with him I said I'm going out
to Hollywood to do my first big movie he
looked at me and he said and you're
going to be nominated for an Academy
Award
I laughed at him and I said and if I am
you will fly out and you will be my
escort I was nominated and he flew out
to be my escort the event was held on
his birthday
when I received a call from my agent
telling me that he had some good news
for me I assumed that it was going to be
that I was to receive an Emmy Award for
a segment that I have done on how to get
away with murder I had been nominated
four times and so I said well I guess
they decided they finally they're going
to give me one this time
so he said Robert said but he wants to
tell you himself
I said he who the president of the
Academy he said his name is mr. baby and
I will put him on and so mr. Bailey got
on the phone
introduced himself and said Cicely it
gives me great joy to tell you that
yesterday the board of governors all 54
or 50 of them decided to give you an
honorary Oscar well
to tell you I just went to water I could
not say a word and I have to tell you I
don't recall ever receiving any
information that sent me into such I
call it an I Agri Falls because I
couldn't stop and you can ask mr. Bale
himself he'll tell you I couldn't say a
word all I did was cry I cried and cried
and cried I said nothing
I don't think I said thank you mr.
Bailey where are you thank you I'm so
sorry
I'm sorry I didn't get a chance but I
could not in any case I returned to New
York and I went to my friend's home to
share this news he wasn't there and so I
called and I called several times it's
very unlike him to receive a call for me
and not respond immediately and so
finally I decided oh never mind I'm
going to tell you the story and I
reminded him of what he said to me 45
years ago I said I want to share
something with you this time I have it
and this time I am asking you to repeat
your performance and escort me to
California to accept this treasure not
realizing that he was ill and that he
was in the hospital and that he never
got my message or my invitation for him
to escort me to accept this incredible
honor his name was Arthur Mitchell and
he passed two days after that I know
however author wherever you are that
this was what you were promising me and
I want to thank you I want to thank the
members of the Academy the governor's
every single one of you who have made it
a point to be here to let me know how
much you have supported me all these
years I could not be here if it were not
for you if you had not stood beside me
around me under me and made me feel you
know sometimes when you plan to do
something you hope that it's going to
turn out the way you want it to it's
just an overused to do that
and so it just lets me know that you
have to have a certain amount of faith
and trust and belief in what you do
quincy said that I said over and over
again that I am led by divine guidance
it's when I go against it that I get
myself into trouble that's sure Oprah
thank you I know what it took for you to
get here what we go over wherever you
are I am and we'll be eternally grateful
to you mom I know you didn't want me to
do this but I did
and here it is
[Laughter]
and I know that for the longest time I
wanted to hear something positive from
her it took her a long time and when I
did Jane Pittman I called her up the
next day when I got the recognition and
I said to her well she said well what I
said you better tell me something and
she said I am so proud of you and I
think that if I had not heard those
words from her none of this would make a
difference to me
above all I hope you know next month on
December 19th I'm going to be 94 years
[Applause]
and I don't know that I would cherish a
better gift than this this is the
culmination of all those years of haves
and have-nots and God bless you all
thank you thank you thank you